now the question is in 2024 who replaces
joe biden if
the republicans do win who is the
president going to be there is a new
poll just came out
nearly 58 percent of republicans
nearly six and ten
would nominate
donald trump again trump is absolutely
dominating the republican presidential
field number two this was a little
surprising to me mike pence mike pence
comes in second with 13
ron desantis comes in third with only
nine percent we're talking about rhonda
santos as though he's the republican
nominee he's only got nine percent
support
uh rubio and nikki haley both have about
three percent
now the question shifts
when you take trump out of the field
so if trump is not in the field the
numbers are very different
pence comes in on top with 32 support
ron desantis with 20 support
ted cruz with 14 support the rest i
think are
yeah a little bit too low to care about
right now so
what does this mean it means one
donald trump is still considered to be
the strongest republican he's the one
who is punching back against
not just the liberal establishment but
his own establishment which is a pretty
amazing thing
that the republicans still support him
six out of 10 republicans still support
him
but i think it also shows you that the
people who are ready to just crown ron
desantis right now desantis is doing a
great job i don't mean to
speak ill of what he's doing in florida
but the people who are willing to crown
him i think are are getting ahead of
themselves there's still a long way to
go i'm so glad you like that clip i like
that clip too i thought it was pretty
good
if you would like more of that kind of
content head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play subscribe
to the michael knowles show
t h e space m i c h a e l space k w l e
s space s h o w
t h a n k s
s e e y o u n e x t
t i m e
[Music]
[Music]